make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay um under normal circumstances we
would do too powerful for the Marvel
movies right but we're not because like
in game just came out it's like the
weekend of the weekend of the movies
released I imagine most people are going
to see it I probably saw it last night
and a lot of people definitely want to
see you today I saw the movie times it's
like a bajillion movie times it's
smashed like every almost every box
office record I haven't looked at a list
of all of them but it's made like 300
million dollars and like just these two
days just like Thursday and Friday like
it's it's it's insane
how much money this movie is making
it'll it'll break the record for avatar
let's gonna smash avatar it's it's it's
crazy
um having said that I can't be too loud
because morai is upstairs sleeping and
so I don't want to wake her up because
like you say you wake Mariah up from her
beauty sleep woe betide the poor soul
who does that like it's it's man you are
you're in for it if you make that
mistake and it's kind of sunny outside
okay so uh it's like spoilers this is
gonna have spoilers for Avengers in game
that's why I'm just you know so you guys
are we're uh beta ray bill now here's
the thing
this did not initially occur to me like
it didn't even cross my mind like when I
was sitting in the theater and I was
watching the theater I uploaded the
video yesterday and like a lot of times
I'll go through the comments just to see
like ideas that you guys have because I
don't cuz you guys usually like a lot of
the guys think of things that I don't
and so I was like okay so so this was
this is you guys this is not me I don't
know figure this this is you guys you
guys were pointing out the fact that
like Thor is now on like basically join
the guardians of the galaxy right like
so Thor's party there got into the
galaxy team which it's kind of cool
because normally I would have an Iron
Man but of course Tony Stark is dead and
um in anyway so so Thor's part of the
guardians he's gonna take off into space
and and people like you guys were
leaving a slew of comets and you were
like Rob do you know what they're going
to do and and and and it's like wow I
don't know what are they gonna do with
Thor and going into the galaxy and
people are just like beta ray bill and I
was like oh my god
I was like oh my god they're gonna do
baby bear deal look here's the here's
okay so here's the thing so so during
wall sinus is when I'm for an issue
number 337 beta ray bill was introduced
and and the way this played out is that
Nick Fury had contacted Thor because
there was a ship that was entering the
solar system and it was really like
pretty close to Earth and Nick Fury was
like you'd have to go out there and you
have to check it out this is long before
the introduction of sword right so like
shield kind of does double duty on
keeping an eye on things that involve
earth but not really looking out into
the greater landscape of space and so
Thor goes and responds the work comes
across the ships scuttlebutt and then
like basically a fight breaks out
between him and like beta ray bill and
so so what you end up learning is that
that beta ray bill and like he's
basically a group a member of a race
called the korbinites you know they're
you know from a planet corbin and
they're their galaxy had seemingly been
destroyed by like Serdar and fire demons
and so they were like the last survivors
of their race and there are basically
refugees they were just like trying to
find a place to live and the galaxy
somewhere but using technology beta ray
bill is basically augmented and he
became kind of like us like their own
Captain America s sort of character
insofar as he was like a protector of
their people and so when Thor showed up
and then scuttlebutt since Thor is a
threat they woke up beta ray bill the
fight broke out between the two of them
and this was during the era when if the
were losses hammer for 60 seconds he
turned back into Donald Blake and the
hammer turned back into a king and so
because of this when the fight breaks
out between the two of them Thor
separated from his hammer for 60 seconds
he's knocked unconscious as Donald Blake
bye-bye beta ray bill and then beta ray
bill picks up the cane snatch it on the
ground and then becomes like basically
gets the power of Thor now this is this
is this is very important thing and the
reason why is because beta ray bill was
the first person in the history of
Marvel Comics to wield the hammer of
Thor now at this point in time and I'm
almost cinematic universe that sort of
cool thing has been lost in reality I
think it was a mistake letting vision be
the first one to lift the hammer of Thor
I think it should've been Captain
America I think Captain America should
own the first one to pick it up it was
cool to see an Avengers in game but how
much more impactful would it have been
had vision not lifted it beforehand
right because like you can
ring that bell like you can't go back
and not you know say well that didn't
actually happen it did like there's
there's no way to get around that and so
so it was really awesome to see and and
like watching Captain America beat the
hell out of fan outs with the the hammer
of Thor was probably one of the most
boss ass things I've ever seen in my
life
but in any kind of book movie ever but
the impact of that moment was lost
because vision was the first one lifted
and so what that means is that if beta
ray bill comes along
there's the impact of beta ray bill
arriving would not be the most
significant thing in the world if
anything it would be fanservice
it would just breathe it would just
bring in a Thor fan favorite and like
that would be it right because it'd be
different if Captain America didn't pick
it up and it would be different vision
ever picked up the hammer of Thor and
instead beta ray bill was the one to do
it for the problem with that is the
significance of picking up the hammer of
Thor basically comes in like this
situation like for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it's situational for comics
it's just kinda like okay cool so
somebody paint somebody's the first
person ever picked it up and it's a huge
thing because you've got this huge
expansive history of Thor and like Walt
Simonson had like this really amazing
run with all these seven things not the
best run I think Jason Aaron has the
best run but the fact remains that for
the casual movie goer it has to be like
a situational right that's why I say
Captain America picking it up if he'd
been the only one to ever do it would
have been a lot cooler because it's like
desperate times call for desperate
measures
but the fact remains that that brie beta
ray bill and would be cool but it would
not be the biggest thing everybody would
just be a person that's being thrown in
there um in reality and this is gonna go
against the grain for a lot of people
who were beta ray bill fans and that's
probably gonna piss them off don't
really care I would not let beta ray
bill pick up for his hammer like I would
remove that from from and that's kind of
a crazy thing because it's really the
only thing that makes him significant
now the Brotherhood that formed between
beta ray bill and Thor so those guys who
are unfamiliar with comics whatever Thor
needs help he goes to beta ray bill
he'll go to the Avengers but like beta
ray bill and Thor like the brothers
essentially you know like warrior
brothers but that was that that bond was
forged more through conflict than the
fact that like beta ray bill picked up
the hammer of Thor and so because of
that
I would not have beta ray bill pick up
the hammer of Thor instead I would give
him the storm breaker so here's the way
this played out in Marvel Comics because
beta ray bill picked up the hammer of
Thor the question was who deserves to be
worthy and so there was essentially a
small little duel or contest of sorts
that was held between beta ray bill and
and Thor and I think that they rebuild
won the contest but because of the
circumstance um Odin basically fashioned
for beta ray bill his own hammer called
storm breaker and that's that it's it
looks different than the one that you
see right now in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but for all intensive purposes
it's the same thing in reality in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe the giant axe
thing the Thor wields that's your
viewing it is called a different name
but they called storm breaker in a films
so whatever you do is you bring beta ray
bill in and you basically say okay so
like beta ray bill is some guy who's
trying to escape or whatever some fight
breaks out between him and the guardians
of the galaxy
maybe he lifts Florist hammer I don't
really know but whatever the case says
the word begins to see him as more of
like an ally and a friend then with the
two of them working together they
basically go forward and and you know
they write Bill Gates Stormbreaker and
they fight his you know brothers in arms
more or less or something along those
lines now the reason why I say I would
not give beta ray bill the hammer of
Thor is because at that point what
you're running into is you're running
into losing the effect right like right
wrong or otherwise over the years
Marvel's had a lot of people lift the
hammer of Thor right like beta ray bill
was the first you've had Captain America
who lifted it
Captain America only did it in the
moment though right like that's one of
the big things that's one of the big
misconceptions Captain America did it in
the moment the first time you did it and
then the second time he legit picked it
up you know like I think it was during
fear itself or something like that he
legit picked up the hammer and like
wielded it but the fact remains that
that one of the big complaints that Thor
fans have right now which I think to see
what they're coming from although to me
you saw that huge would deal anymore but
one of the big complaints that they have
is that the the nature of being able to
wield Thor's hammer like the
significance of somebody picking up
Thor's hammer is long since gone because
so many people have done it like the
novelty's worn off so it's like you know
Thor loses his hammer then like somebody
picks it up and instead of it being like
oh my god how do you know it's just kind
of like cool and then like you turn the
page and that's it you know and that's
that's really
you get out of it it's one of those
things that that's that that people say
is done for the sake of shock value as
opposed to like genuinely benefiting the
story and so because that that's the
risk you run into you in the MCU because
what you would have is over the course
of three films spanning five or six
years you've had vision Captain America
and now beta ray bill all lift the
hammer of Thor and basically it would
give the perception out to the general
to the average moviegoer everybody's
worthy of wielding Thor's hammer and and
that's not what you want you want the
hair to be a very coveted thing you want
somebody who manages to pick up Thor's
hammer for it to be a very significant
thing it rarely ever happens right like
it's like over the course of the life of
the MCU it might happen maybe five more
times but like that's it like like it
and and when I say over the life of the
MCU I mean like the next like 50 years
it happens like five times like once
every 10 years it'll happen and and
that's it you know you don't want to
overdo it and I feel like with beta ray
bill doing it's so close to since
succession you know because we know
we're gonna basically get the new
Guardian like guardians of the galaxy
three it already film it already
finished finished filming and so as far
as I'm aware our guardians three rule
will basically take place before the
events of infinity or before the events
of endgame I'm assuming it well like I'm
humming you know before even probably
even before Infinity Ward I don't think
anybody has any details on the script
about a high person sure I haven't
really looked into it but I doubt Thor
will be a part of that team and so we
could largely assume that because Marvel
Comics now has as guardians of the
galaxy that because Marvel Comics copies
the mobile cinematic universe that what
you're gonna see is basically like
guarding to the galaxy for which is
essentially gonna be adds guardians of
the galaxy so you got the Thor you know
my so on and so forth but still bigger
if that will be a really really cool
thing and again there's there's other
benefits to come out of beta ray bill
aside from the fact that you can lift
Thor's hammer the camaraderie between
him and Thor is amazing to see like it's
you know yes brother I'm always here I'm
always on your side it's one of these
things where like now they have another
powerhouse that's out there that could
be used for the purpose of like fighting
me some foe or something along those
lines but really introducing beta
rebuild as cool as it would be would
really just be fanservice which is not a
bad thing I mean they can bring in bring
in god that you know more the god
butcher that's just fanservice
I mean sure he's powerful enough to kill
all the Avengers but he never fought all
the offender's he only fought like Thor
over three different time periods which
would still be bad ask to see but but
you know
beta ray bill would just be fanservice
really to thor fans you know I mean
again nothing in the world but you can
make a plot out of it but I think
there's other characters out there other
villains that are out there other
stories that can be done that I think
would be more impactful and more
interesting than the story of beta ray
bill but I mean I would do that for like
a standalone Thor film if they made like
a for for you know for rather one of the
things you guys will notice too about
the MCU is they never do more than three
films on a singular character well you
got Iron Man Iron Man one two and three
Captain America one two and three four
one two and three
you got Ant Man one and two are getting
ant-man mmm three um you know that's
that's really it you only ever get like
trilogy when it comes to when it comes
to character which is smart you know
system I remove Avengers one two and
three like that's basically it so um
it's a cool little thing but but
nonetheless you know I like the idea I
like the notion behind it but I would
not necessarily look to it as a big huge
event right like I would look to it as
like a singular Thor film so if they
decide to make a Thor which I don't
think they would then I think beta ray
bill would do well there and then
feature him and other stories with the
ferreters later on down the line but I
would not make him in a make him a
villain of like the New Avengers film
like New Avengers I would not make him a
villain of that film I would not make
him a villain of anybody but a Thor film
or Thor on the is guardians of the
guardians of the galaxy team that would
be it like that would literally be you
know the limits of the thinker's the way
that the way that would play out would
be simple enough like you literally have
Thor and the guardians who were
travelling through space they run across
scuttlebutt and like the the ship with
all the korbinites on it
and like they go to investigate and this
ship believes they're all the threats
when wakes up later a bill fight breaks
out and then something happens maybe he
lifts a hammer maybe he doesn't I don't
know but something happens and basically
like this like hey everybody stop
fighting we got to hear this guy's story
he tells a story of what happened and
they say okay fine
you know Thor deems him worthy give some
Stormbreaker and then like Thor and beta
ray bill and it got into the galaxy go
over to whatever happened to his planet
and destroy whatever the hell that is
and in the movies done and that's it
like I mean it's it's a pretty simple
process it's not a not an overly
convoluted thing but but yeah I would
keep it limited to effect because big
rebels just not really significant
enough to be a villain for like the
whole like a whole Avengers
route and even if he was there be no
reason for him to because he's a good
guy like is he these views worthy to
lift words hammer he's not a villain you
know he's a good guy I think that
awesome and II would it would be a
pretty cool would be a cool villain and
was it awesome Andy Andy Android I care
it's been so long I want to say that's
awesome Andy but I would either grab him
I think you he'd be a cool but I'm kind
of pulling from from obscurity for that
kind of thing awesome Andy I think would
be a cool thing for or like the the not
the ultra Humanite um what is that guy
the super adaptoid I think it was um
grab him it's something along those
lines like some some character out there
make a cool villain for the New Avengers
next Avengers film but nonetheless you
know I'm kind of rambling here kind of
going on so I'm gonna go ahead now Soph
here guys I'm gonna send this video off
to my editor he's gonna get it put
together hopefully a be up in the next
few hours if you guys are new here too
comments explain make sure you guys to
the sub button to become part of the Rob
coffee guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]